all right all right well this video is
going to be short and sweet you can see
I got a used uh this is a Ford
F150 um a 2010 model uh fourwh drive and
all that good stuff
but I know when I got this I didn't have
I had one key you know this is for the
rear but just this one ignition key and
the key fob here just never worked so I
uh I purchased a couple
more but you can see this time I got the
ones with the key built in I could have
got them separate but I want the the key
built in on them um and the biggest
thing is to get them programmed and I'll
show you how easy it is to do
that so first make sure you have uh the
door open a little
bit and all your doors
unlocked all right so you can see I'm
just going to put the key in the
ignition and cycle it eight times make
sure your door is
unlocked and the door is
open all right did you hear that that
was the door door's opening and
closing the door locks that is so now
I'm going to push unlock on that
one unlock on that one and be sure to do
both of them if you have two and uh and
that's it now turn the key
off the the locks recycled
again off and on so
now there unlock lock
[Music]
and here's the second
one unlock and
lock so that is it so you don't have to
go to a dealer to get it programmed you
can just do it right there at home just
cycle it eight times and wait for it to
to hear the locks go uh it'll lock and
unlock them or vice versa I forget which
one but you you can hear it cycle and
then just go over there and push the
button on your key fob and uh then turn
the ignition off um and you'll hear it
cycle again but that's it it's uh it's
dirt simple um so if you get new fobs
just uh don't go to the dealership to do
it uh just follow these easy steps and
that is it so thanks for watching and
until next time